Let's talk cork tacks.
This is an awesome, decorative way to pin things directly onto your wall.
Simply grab a cork, hollow out about half an inch with a knife,...
...drop in some hot glue and place the tack inside.
Pin up all of your favorite items.
Time for some games.
Want a nice way to kill some time with your guests?
How about cork-tac-toe?
Simply grab a paper plate and draw a big hashtag.
Now, cut up ten pieces of cork at about an eighth of an inch each.
Draw five x's and five circles.
Boom! Hours of fun for your devious hands.
Now, how about some awesome fridge magnets?
Simply cut some corks in half and hot glue simple magnets to the back.
You can typically pick those up at any hardware store.
Now, when you place this on the fridge, you can stand out from the crowd...
...and boast that you consumed far too much wine.